police in Arizona are asking the public
for help to find out who raped a
disabled patient the long tear a
long-term care center now this woman had
been in a vegetative state for around 14
years she gave birth at Hacienda
Healthcare last month her family's
attorney says they are outraged by what
they call abuse and neglect
Omar Villafranca is in Phoenix with more
on this story
Omar good morning to you good morning
Phoenix police want to be clear that
what happened here at Hacienda
Healthcare was rape and they expect this
to be a very long investigation but so
far they have not ruled anyone out
I am hopeful and confident that we will
find who committed this crime
Arizona investigators are hunting for
any DNA evidence using court-ordered
cheek swabs to pinpoint who raped a
female patient at Hacienda Healthcare
right now you're focusing on employees
at Hacienda Healthcare right now we
still have a very wide scope we're
looking at anyone who possibly might
have had contact with this individual
police say they first reported to
Hacienda on December 29th following a
call of an infant in distress both the
woman and the baby were rushed to the
hospital I am led to believe the first
time that anyone knew that a baby was
being that this woman was pregnant was
when she was actually giving birth to
the baby on Monday hacienda CEO Bill
Timmons resigned in a statement
haciendas executive vice president says
the organization will accept nothing
less than a full accounting of this
absolutely horrifying situation people
with disabilities of all types are
actually preyed upon because their
disability at times because they know
they can't fight back because they know
that they can't report
Erica McFadden leads the Arizona Council
that advocates for people with
developmental disabilities she wants
health care workers better trained to
identify sexual abuse and assault we
don't even know if individuals are
giving any kind of training to know if
they know how to report abuse so
something happens to them we don't know
if they even know where to go
the 29 year old woman is a member of the
San Carlos Apache Tribe and police are
telling us that her and the child are
recovering at a local hospital now the
family attorney tells us she gave birth
to a baby boy who was born into a loving
family and will be cared for
bianna well it's nice to hear that but
still so alarming to hear the details of
this and as you said Gail we likely will
find out who did this but at the same
time how did no one else become aware
that wasn't someone taking care of her
in the hospital in a daily basis and the
more you hear the more heartbreaking and
sickening it is but they will get an
answer to this question I do believe and
Omar we'll be following this story
exactly right